[Music]
Nosferatu is a classic but unofficial
cinematic adaptation of Bram Stoker's
1897 novel Dracula the film released in
1922 is a silent German expressionist
horror film and an absolute Masterpiece
that pioneered new techniques and helped
establish horror tropes that remain in
effect even today more than a hundred
years after it was made
but perhaps its greatest contribution to
horror is its reimagining of the vampire
Dracula as count orlock a monster so
iconic that his very Shadow is
recognizable you could even argue that
orlock has spawned his own monstrous
line of progeny one that runs parallel
to the aristocratic Draculas of stoker
and Lugosi but this horrific animalistic
ugly vampire very different from
lugosi's is not maybe quite as popular
as his line but he can still be seen in
film TV shows video games and other
forms of Pop Culture too
I'm Dr Brittany Warman and I'm Dr Sarah
klito and we're folklorists who study
vampires
[Music]
Nosferatu was produced by pranafilm a
short-lived silent era German Film
Studio founded in 1921 by Enrico Dickman
and artist Albin growl it's important to
remember that Nosferatu is an unlicensed
and unofficial adaptation of Bram
Stoker's Dracula it's very obviously
drawing from the book but because a
bunch of the names and the details are
changed product film claimed that it
wasn't really copyright infringement
yeah and this didn't really go that well
for them there was a huge copyright
battle that happened around this film so
Bram Stoker had died by the time the
film was released but his wife Florence
stoker was not pleased she'd actually
already denied the company the rights to
the film they were like we want to make
this movie she was like no thank you but
they went ahead and made it anyway it's
just pretty gutsy right there pretty
gutsy so the stoker estate sued and it
wasn't a hard case for them to win the
original German version of the film had
enter titles that specifically said
Dracula not the greatest mistake to make
if you're trying to claim you weren't
infringing on copyright yeah and the
plot was obviously incredibly similar
they didn't really have a leg to stand
on so after the stoker estate won the
case the judge actually ordered that all
the copies of the film be destroyed so
it's pretty amazing that we even have
this film at all we were this close to
not having Nosferatu which has had such
an enormous impact on you know not only
vampire films but horror films in
general and also just our cultural
conception of what a vampire looks like
and what they act like it's wild
[Music]
so there are a few pretty crucial
differences between the vampire and Bram
Stoker's Dracula and count orlock in
nosferatsu probably the first thing it's
a little obvious is that count orlock is
called orlock instead of Dracula and
again this is largely because of the
copyright issue they were like oh God if
we just straight up call them Dracula
might be in trouble
so
obviously Nosferatu is a silent film so
minimal dialogue and what dialogue there
is is conveyed through writing on
intertile frames
character and ideas have to be conveyed
through body language and facial
expressions rather than the endless
writing generated by all the characters
in Dracula
so Dracula the novel is an epistolary
novel which means that it is compiled
from documents this means it's basically
made up of letters diary entries
sometimes newspaper clippings stuff like
that it's all writing that the
characters themselves have generated
expressing their own points of view like
from their first person perspective so
changing all of this into a format a
silent film where there's almost no
dialogue at all and what dialogue there
is has to show up on the screen written
out is an amazing transformation
most of the action from Nosferatu is
really just like the first third of
Dracula while the second like roughly
two-thirds of the novel are largely
compressed into the final you know like
30 minutes or so of the film
instead there's also much more focus on
the vampire and kind of what he's up to
rather than following a large cast of
characters in Britain
[Music]
oh
Sarah and I are folklorists so one of
the most interesting parts of Nosferatu
to us is that count warlock is much more
like the vampires of folklore than later
cinematic reincarnations of the vampire
he barely passes for human and arguably
he even doesn't pass for human he really
does and he's more like his rats or even
the werewolf which is an amazing part of
this movie they used a striped hyena as
a werewolf in the film and it's pretty
fantastic yeah and we're clearly
supposed to you know equate the vampire
you know with his rats with this
werewolf in the forest that seems to be
you know linked to him in some way and
again this is a lot more like some of
the old folklore we see around vampires
where vampires can't really pass for
human where they're much more
animalistic a lot of the time they're
you know
ugly and gross because they're so
bloated from blood so we're not seeing
that here exactly but we are seeing kind
of a grotesque in humanity that sets him
apart from the people who surround him
even the connection to the werewolf is
really interesting because in folklore
vampires and werewolves are we're not
really the separate categories that we
tend to think give them as today there
was a lot of slippage between the two of
those so we're not sure if orlock is the
werewolf in this movie or if the
werewolves another bad guy hanging out
but the fact that that it exists that
questioning exists seems like an
interesting part of the film too
yeah there's even some old folklore that
suggests that if you are a werewolf in
life you are a vampire in death so
there's this you know long-term link
this possibility pairing these different
kinds of monsters together blurring the
boundaries between them
foreign
[Music]
's performance is what's ultimately the
most mesmerizing thing about it even
today he's got pointed ears hunched
shoulders they stick thin body Talons
extending from the tips of his fingers
his fingers are so long gone to chalk
white face all together it's quite an
impression
also there's just just so many shots of
orloc that are completely iconic now
from his silhouette gliding up the
stairs to his angular Ascent from his
coffin I mean he's just like and like it
feels like that should be funny
it's not no it really isn't and it is
it's still haunting yeah it's still
haunting people you know make fun of it
now and do it as sort of a parody but in
the nosferati film it is legitimately
spooky legitimately spooky and just his
shape in general his shadow it's all
instantly recognizable nowadays
and this is just such a contrast to the
like sort of melodramatic like big
gestures and frenetic activity of the
other actors that surround him and he's
just there silent and still and then
moving very slowly and that contrast
just heightens the difference between
him and the other characters heightens
his own uncanniness and his inhumanity
it really does it creates this
incredible Gothic weirdness
despite its lack of jump scares or showy
set pieces or gory CGI still to use the
famous film critic Roger Ebert's words
is effective it doesn't scare us but it
haunts us
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]